un soir merci Madame la président
avec son projet de loi 12 le ministre de
la Justice Simon jaune et barrettes
tente de colmater une brèche dans le
doigts de la famille
[Applaudissements]
le nombre d'enfants qui naissent à la
suite d'une agression sexuelle chaque
année au Québec à l'avenir une femme
violée pourra s'opposer à ce que son
enfant est un lien de filiation avec son
agresseur et celui-ci devra contribuer à
ses besoins par le paiement d'une
indemnité nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est
qu'on veut laisser la liberté aux femmes
qui ont été violées de choisir qu'est-ce
qui leur convient le mieux établissement
d'affiliation refus complet de
l'affiliation obtention d'une indemnité
ou d'échéance de l'autorité parentale en
fonction de la situation particulière de
la personne qui est victime cet aspect
du projet de loi fait grandement écho au
cas d'Océane qui a choisi de taire son
nom en nous dernier la jeune femme a
lancé un cri du cœur afin d'être mieux
protégé par la loi québécoise il y a
trois ans elle agresser sexuellement par
son colocataire et amis depuis elle est
tombée enceinte son agresseur qui
réclame la paternité de l'enfance est
adressée au tribunaux pour exiger un
test d'ADN la tente d'Océane qui
souhaite parler en son nom de manière
anonyme ça vous soulager même si la
bataille est loin d'être terminée on a
enfin vu comme le fruit de notre travail
parce que
ça fait déjà un certain temps qu'on
était sur
cette cet objectif-là pour la directrice
générale de jury pop il faudra analyser
en profondeur le projet de loi pour
éviter des situations indésirables le
code de CM est assez clair c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu une seule relation sexuelle
non consensuelle de laquelle a découlé
une grossesse par contre la réalité peut
varier dans certains cas la mer aurait
le faire doux de démontrer que la
naissance de l'enfant est bel et bien le
fruit d'une agression
te crée aussi que la location fournie
par l'agresseur ne deviennent un levier
pour contrôler sa victime ici Gabriel
prou Radio-Canada Montréal